When it comes to comic book movies, it's important
to have a certain amount of suspension of
disbelief. Still, sometimes you can't help
but wonder exactly how some plot turns went
down. While Captain America: Civil War was
awesome from start to finish, there were
some moments that made us go, "Hey, wait,
a minute..." Oh, and watch out...major spoilers
ahead.
Blurred Vision
The event that kick-starts the movie into
motion is the battle against Crossbones in
Lagos, Nigeria, which ends with the villain
attempting to explode Captain America and
himself to bits. He fails in his attempt,
thankfully, when Scarlet Witch shifts the
blast elsewhere. Unfortunately, her actions
accidentally lead to the deaths of several
relief aid workers. You know who probably
could've saved the day?
The Vision, who simply wasn't there. It's
not like he has an exciting personal life
or anything, so why was he absent? It's never
explained. But if we had to guess...it's because
his presence would've changed the nature of
the fight. And prevented that part of the
plot from working.
No spin zone
Before unveiling the Sokovia Accords, General
Ross takes the Avengers for a guilt trip down
memory lane. He reflects on the various incidents
that have taken place since their inception
as a team, focusing on the innocent casualties
and damages that happened as a result.
The Battle of New York is one of his key talking
points—although he avoids mentioning how
the World Security Council ordered a nuclear
strike against the alien invasion in Manhattan,
which certainly would've caused far more damage
than the Avengers did.
Why didn't someone from the Avengers speak
up and point that out?
You'd also think that someone on the team
would've noted that Scarlet Witch's actions
in Lagos saved even more lives by removing
Crossbones' blast from ground level, which
was much more populated.
In fact, pretty much all the incidents Ross
mentions would have been way worse without
the Avengers intervening, right? Shouldn't
one of the super-people mentioned that…?
OK, that's enough,
All about timing
Since the events of Avengers: Age of Ultron
that led to the deaths of his family, Civil
War bad guy Helmut Zemo plans to destroy
the Avengers by causing inner conflict, disintegrating
the group from within. What's confusing, though,
is that a lot of his plan seems dependent
on the Sokovia Accords. And they didn't even
come into play until well after his plan started,
right?
Let's just accept that he's fast on his feet
and adapted to the situation. Just like this
next situation...
What if Iron Man hadn't shown up?
So Zemo's big plan all along was to tear down
the Avengers by turning them against each
other right? When he shows Tony Stark the
video of his parents being slain by Bucky
while he was in Winter Soldier mode. Tempers flare
all around, and Cap's relationship with Iron
Man goes up in smoke. Hooray for Zemo! On
the other hand, what was Zemo planning to
do if Iron Man hadn't flown in when he did?
It's not like he had any reason to believe
that Iron Man was arriving: it was a spontaneous
decision.
Of course, if there's one thing you can set
your watch to, it's Tony making crazy,
disastrous, spontaneous decisions…
So maybe we'll give them partial credit on
that one.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
Channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which plot holes we missed...